[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines no guesses tonight
with the consultant editor of the daily
mail andrew pearce and the associate
editor of the daily mirror kev maguire
to discuss a very busy day certainly so
to the front pages then let us start
with the metro time to go away and shut
up or take a foreign holiday that's the
metro's lead headline on the day gavin
williamson was sacked as education
secretary as part of that cabinet
reshuffle the eye says boris johnson has
sacked what it describes as his
blundering cabinet allies and pictures
the main winners and losers of the shake
up
johnson wheels acts in cabinet reshuffle
that's the lead for the times
while the financial times says the
clear-out signals an attempt to revive
support for mr johnson's agenda for
domestic reform
the guardian meanwhile says it's moved
to set mr johnson up for the next
election
daily telegraph highlighting dominick
robb and michael gove as two of the main
losers in the reshuffle
but the yorkshire post says michael
gove's new job at housing will be a
significant role for the north as part
of the plans for economic and social
leveling up
daily mirror investigates climate change
and shows a flooded street as a warning
of what will happen if we don't act now
although i see gavin williamson is still
at the top of your paper kevin so let's
get uh get the thoughts on today andrew
pierce and kevin mcguire andrew we
didn't know he had it had it in him
boris johnson going all brutal what
happened
well you know people say he's um he
ducks uh confrontation and that's true
to a point because this reshuffle is
long overdue he hasn't had a proper
reshuffle since what february 2020 when
he took over from theresa may he called
most of her terrible ministers but this
is a major reshuffle it really is
significant uh a new foreign secretary
only the second woman foreign secretary
she's the darling of the tour he faced
for because she's pulled off so many uh
trade deals as international business
secretary and not all of them are hugely
uh
valuable in terms of money but it's good
for morale and um dominic rabb of course
demoted uh but not without a struggle
he's been moved side
definitely downwards to uh justice
secretary but there was an unseemly
struggle where he
obviously stamped his feet and uh folded
his arms and refused to cooperate until
he got the bauble of deputy prime
minister which doesn't mean a lot really
i'm trying to think who the last one was
it was in 2015 so that might have been
damian green
can't remember um but um if that if that
placates rob sophia but he had to go
from foreign secretary because he was
found wanting during the great
evacuation from afghanistan he didn't
interrupt his holiday
he didn't make a very important phone
call which he should have made to his
opposite number in pakistan which might
have helped some of those afghan
translators and interpreters who risked
their lives for the government and the
british military to get out of kabul and
quite a lot of them unfortunately is
still there
yes and in fact the times uh quentin
let's his political sketch says so dom
how does it feel to be the new nick
clegg because he was the famous deputy
prime minister of course in that
coalition government wasn't he but uh
johnson wheels the axe in the cabinet
reshuffle i mean good for him in some
respects keeping a job he could have
just gone he could have flounced off
couldn't he um kevin but the other big
one i suppose is gavin williamson you
know you do wonder if this reshuffle was
aimed at losing people like williamson
and moving rob what do you reckon
well i think dominic rob must now regret
not backing labour's plan to outlaw fire
and rehire because he gets fired as a
foreign secretary and then he's rehired
in a more lowly position as justice
secretary but getting that title of the
deputy prime minister it's a bit
unseemly when he's uh he's hiding for
himself but it does mean he will get and
continue to retain access to the chi
evening country house in kent where he
can lie on those sun lounges rather than
in the med but gavin williamson we just
saw pictures of him uh
there i mean he he was the most useless
education secretary in history he's
given an interview to his local paper
that will have an expression style which
he claims he's left education in a good
place i think he's probably the only
person in the entire united kingdom if
not the cosmos who thinks that is the
the case but one thing i do i just pick
uh an andrew odd is he said it's a big
reshuffle in some ways it is because
four ministers are out of the cabinet
but when you keep two of the three great
officers of state unchanged uh the the
chancellor rishi sunak and pretty patel
has survived as the uh the home
secretary despite failing on our own
terms over for instance uh migration and
people in boats over the uh over the
channel so she can count herself pretty
lucky maybe she's just got one last
chance look he should have supported
brexit that may have may have helped her
i just i just wonder how significant the
changes really are education is a big
change uh foreign secretary of course
although liz truss who's uh replaced it
will be out of a depth in a puddle and
uh housing is gonna be quite interesting
because it's michael gove who has
the ability to be radical if he wishes
he could have made a good justice
secretary if he's been there but liz
trust is or if she's the minister for
instagram all she likes to do is have
pictures of herself posing
around the world so i suppose that's
what she thinks global britain is we'll
see uh everywhere just just pitches over
yeah i'm interested on gov just quickly
that the telegraph suggests he's lost
out here because the times points out as
did the tweet from the prime minister
that this is all about the um leveling
up agenda and of course as well as
housing uh mr gove your great friend
andrew um has to protect the union and
deliver leveling up which seemed two big
planks of the of the government's agenda
in the years ahead
yeah look he's moved from cabinet office
where he had a roving brief he was very
involved behind the scenes in lots of
different projects and um some ministers
said he rather interfered too much but
he was bored he wanted out of that and
housing actually is a hugely hugely
important part of the whole leveling up
process uh boris johnson's expression
leveling up they've got to sort out some
of those northern constituencies which
have been neglected for decades and
housing is a key part of it now his
predecessor robert generic came up with
a brilliant idea to alienate every tory
backbencher and every tory councillor of
building massively on tory greenbelt
land ridiculous nobody wanted that
there's lots of brownfield sites that
can be developed there's lots of
existing housing that can be uh improved
and i think michael gove far from being
demoted i think he's one of the more
interesting appointments because he is
one of the cleverest people in the
cabinet by a long chalk even kevin
mcguire will concede that and he is a
radical thinker he was radical at
education but too radical for david
cameron who booted him out of that job
so i think it's a big job he's also got
to sort out the union in scotland that's
a problem he did his bit for the union
by dancing rather badly in that night
clubbing aberdeen a couple of weeks ago
and he's also got another little job too
he's got to make sure christmas isn't
ruined by um hgv lorry shortages food
shortages uh because christmas was a
disaster politically last year the prime
minister put a lot of political capital
in saying we would have a proper
christmas and then we didn't so goat's
got quite a lot on his plate and on his
entree and it's life is always
interesting when gabe's around i would
say yes
i'm sorry
we talked about lorry driver shortages
and there are they were partly caused
not entirely but partly caused by brexit
which michael gove backed if andrew
talks about leveling up well today we
have grinding down because we saw the
conservatives abstained on the universal
credit cuts there's about six billion
quid gonna be taken from six million
families forty percent who are working
many of them up north it's not leveling
up it is grinding down and then secondly
andrew says oh god there's all these
brownfield sites to build houses i agree
where you can get reclaimed land build
houses but that's not always always the
case and i think the planning reforms
are now probably dead not least because
michael gove is the mp for surrey heath
in the surrey commuter belt where there
was a very strong nimby tendency uh and
people will not want to be building the
houses in their areas they want them
somewhere else that's that keeps
happening now people say yeah i've got
to build houses but i don't want them
near me where are they going to be built
well that was going to be my question to
you sorry let me just just finish which
is the point that that the the reforming
departments had not been seen to be
delivering including including housing
not a good day to be called robert and
be in the cabinet the eye pictures one
of them who was the ex-housing minister
and my question was to you was going to
be will they try and bring some of this
stuff back that was failing or is that
gone and we move on um andrew what's
your thoughts on on that the planning
forms of reforms for one of those ones
it's the planning reforms uh that
generic envisaged who got the push as
housing secretary as i say building on
greenbelt which helped the tories lose
that by-election in cheshire and amazon
no chance there's other ways that they
can take that forward but i just want to
say to kevin about uh benefit the
benefit reduction the 20 pounds that's
being removed he knows that one of the
great consequences of brexit is wages
are going up because employers can no
longer rely on cheap imported labor from
eastern europe which is why uh waitrose
and academy are starting to pay proper
wages for hgv lorry drivers which who
were retiring in vast numbers not
because of brexit because of the the
complete the working conditions are
appalling and the pay has been terrible
and in decline as kevin well knows and
being a great trade union supporter
kevin i thought you'd be thrilled to see
wages going up yeah you've uh you oppose
every other attempt to
raise wages but of course lorry drivers
deserve to get more if they can get
right glad you agree
on shortages but you you should know
well i hope you've got a better grasp
andrew of the benefit system of his
coffee the dwp second secretary who is
surviving and doesn't deserve to survive
and if people help
more there's a taper that takes away
about 65 p in every pound they earned
let's let's get do you mind if we focus
back
you don't take away their benefits you
don't take away 20 quid and here he goes
here he goes
all right let's let's focus back do you
mind just very quickly the guardian i
just want to run through quickly pm's
ruthless reshuffle lays the ground for
the next election not quite sure how
that's delivered there and if you don't
mind let's plunge inside the metro to
pick up the very story in a sense that
you were talking about kevin which is
inflation hitting a decade high
which is that um all those people
including those on universal credit
he'll lose that top up are finding life
much more expensive clearly and
everyone's still talking about those
shortages that we've already mentioned
the rising price of getting anything to
do any building uh shops you know empty
and my question was this really is that
this comes at a crucial time in
departmental spending bids as we head to
a budget does it neuter all those
efforts to get more money for all those
departments now do you think the timing
of this
oh i think we're going to see
departments outside of health possibly
defence will be cut there's gonna be a
huge squeeze on uh the the chancellor
often likes to play father christmas but
then he he's actually scrooge when you
look what's inside his uh his sack and
it's for many people it's a terrible
time because if you're one of those six
low-paid families you're going to lose
your universal credit the 40 percent who
are in work if they're uh earning over 9
000 a year will start paying not higher
national insurance and then your
situation up 3.2 percent well nurses
were getting three percent but police
officers and
others in the public services were
getting nothing so there would be a cut
in living standards i i think uh boris
johnson thinks he can get away with it
but there's going to be a day of
reckoning people will see through
and all of a sudden he will find that
they're just not laughing with him
yeah one one more thought as we look
through the faces that the papers have
chosen to put on the front the financial
times as well liz trust michael gove
dominic rob gavin williamson with the up
up down and out
which i quite like and then if we go
back to the eye again two people we
haven't talked about uh one
the the former vaccines minister
promoted and nadine doris now i'm a
celebrity fans will remember her people
who like her book to remember her she's
quite colorful isn't she for the role of
culture secretary andrew just quickly
i think she's a terrific choice she's
she's outspoken she's controversial
she's anti-woke she'll give the bbc a
hard time uh she's she's um she she's uh
she will be really lively she's written
books she's appeared on a reality tv
show i'm a celebrity was it i'm supposed
to get me out of here
so she knows about entertainment she's
her book sell very well and she's
cheered up a lot of tory mps because um
that was a surprise appointment and she
will be lively and she will shake things
up channel 4 is due to be privatized
good should never been in a state owned
in the first place and she will keep the
bbc on its toes and so she should
because the bbc is a hotbed of left-wing
buyers and she will be putting that and
pointing that out on a regular basis in
her usual provocative outspoken way good
good appointment i remember anna when
nadine dorrie's about a decade ago said
70 percent of her blog telling
constituents how hard-working
she was where it was actually fiction
absolute fiction she was writing fiction
because it didn't match up to her
expenses claims i think she's got two
jobs uh at culture one is to privatize
channel four which you'll find nobody
thinks is a good idea outside of small
group of right wingers like andrew and
some in the the tour report you were set
up by margaret thatcher you're you know
here you want to get out of a word with
your life size cut out when you get home
uh later tonight